you know the internet we use it for
almost literally everything food
transportation entertainment education
but in the u.s. there are still areas
without internet access we're somewhere
at the bottom of the list when we look
at leading developed nations in terms of
broadband penetration broadband speeds
and broadband prices in fact 10% of
Americans don't have broadband internet
which means they can't even stream this
video you're watching right now it's not
a question of just lacking access to the
Internet it's more like lacking the full
capacity to use the Internet in the way
that it's being used the difficulty of
getting online is a really big deal for
the almost 5 million American households
with school-aged children why because
that's a lot of students who may be
unable to complete their digital
assignments lack of Internet access is
such a concern some school districts
have equipped school buses with routers
so students can get online the
discussion about Internet access is
really about this is access to the
Internet a human right hey fam I'm Amaya
and this Sunday on AG plus works boy
what it's like to live in a digitally
connected nation and yet have limited or
no internet access
[Music]
maybe you've already heard about the
United States digital divide there are a
lot of Americans with limited or no
access to the Internet in rural America
39% of Americans lack broadband access
but what's surprising is how many people
in big cities like Detroit and Miami
black access to broadband and what we
mean by lacking access is having a
broadband connection slower than 25
megabits per second for downloads and 3
megabits per second for uploads with
that connection speed a family of four
would be unable to independently stream
four HD movies simultaneously an
estimated four percent of urban homes
are underserved when it comes to
Internet access and as for people like
small business owner at Reese Watkins to
come up with workarounds to get online
sometimes you can do stuff like go to a
cafe but again it's like how many like
$4 lattes are you paying for in order to
administer your business like three or
four days a week
Watkins limited internet access extends
to our work and home for her getting
online is cost prohibitive it would cost
about like 90 bucks with most standard
service providers her struggle isn't
unique broadband is expensive and the
cost makes it unaffordable for many
nearly half of Americans with household
incomes below $30,000 a year have no
home broadband at all and low-income
homes with children are four times more
likely to lack broadband as middle or
high-income families
what's even more stunning is how the
price of broadband in the u.s. compares
with other countries
I'll let communications professor Victor
Picard explain compared to other leading
democracies around the world the u.s.
typically has lower speeds poorer
services and much more expensive
services in comparison an analysis of
internet prices in the US and France
found the cost in the United States
where as much as three and a half times
higher than those in France for similar
service and it's not like the u.s. is
getting more for all that extra money
the nation only ranks 10th in the world
behind places like South Korea Norway
and Sweden when it comes to bra
and so not only our customers in the
United States paying more they're also
getting fewer choices with slower speeds
but the connectivity issue is about more
than affordability it disproportionately
affects communities of color poor
communities rural communities so still
very much a major social problem in the
United States today even low-income area
residents who can afford home Internet
often have to deal with very slow speeds
this year three African American
low-income residents of Cleveland Ohio
filed a complaint with the FCC the woman
claimed AT&T has withheld high-speed
infrastructure from the overwhelming
majority of blocks with poverty rates
above 35 percent it's a practice some
called Digital redlining in their
complaint they accuse eighty of unjust
and unreasonable discrimination which if
true would be a violation of the
Communications Act or at least it was
but that was before FCC Chairman Ajit
pie garnered enough votes to overturn
the regulation by the way that's the
same ruling that killed net neutrality
pie has also suggested lowering the
goalposts for what constitutes
acceptable speeds for broadband and that
could affect how much funding is
available to expand broadband networks
and to rural our low-income areas so
people who are underserved might be
deemed to have acceptable internet
speeds as eat pie is also the man who
suggested a smartphone can be your
primary vehicle to get online which is
curious because he's also the guy who
began scaling back internet and phone
subsidies for low-income families even
if you accept using a smartphone as a
primary source for internet access is
reasonable realize that 23% of all
smartphone owners have had to cancel
service at some point because of cost
low-income smartphone owners are even
more likely to drop the service because
of price and that's a problem in a world
where we do so much online access to
broadband is no longer a luxury it's a
necessity for everything ranging from
education to health to livelihood not to
mention entertainment or just getting
information communicating with our loved
one
we have to have access to broadband
services you also need broadband to make
it easier to run your small business as
a tree SWOT khun's has discovered not
having it can cost you it was really
difficult for me to start accepting
credit card payments there were people
who stopped wanting to do business with
me because I wouldn't and if I'm at a
venue where I have bad cell signal and
there's no Wi-Fi I can't make sure I got
paid I can't make sure my payment
processed we use the internet daily just
like water say electricity can you
imagine the nation having the same
debate we're having about Internet
access about electricity oh wait you
don't have to because we already did in
1932 only about 10 percent of rural
America had electricity about half of
those people had to buy their own power
plants you had very similar discussions
about whether electricity should be seen
as a necessity or a luxury it parallels
many of the discussions we're having
today around broadband access should the
internet be seen as a necessity is it
even a human right as some would argue
we don't go in and tell people that they
can have more or less water pressure
based on how much they pay their water
bill we don't tell people rather they
can have dim or bright lights based on
how much they pay today we don't
consider electricity a luxury it's a
utility Harvard Law Professor Susan
Crawford says high-speed Internet access
has the potential to affect the USA's
economic growth the way electricity did
so should we regulate internet
accessibility in the same way we do
electricity that's not on PI's to-do
list
he believes the FCC is restoring
Internet freedom by deregulating and
eliminating burdensome and unnecessary
requirements he claims that will free up
ISPs like Comcast and AT&T to invest in
the necessary infrastructure to improve
connectivity for underserved Americans
but Picard doesn't believe that's true
he says PI's actions are less
deregulation and more regulation as PI's
FCC is basically restructuring the
industry to serve corporate interest
he says there's little incentive for
ISPs to provide consumers with a better
over the Internet's lifetime the ISP
market has consolidated to the point
where there are just two companies
providing access in some parts of the
country there's only one which is
effectively a monopoly and it gets more
problematic millions are actually forced
to choose a company that's blocked
certain applications one option for
improving access for Americans is
municipally-owned Internet service
providers
it's what Chattanooga Tennessee has done
it's citywide fiber internet network is
among the fastest and most affordable
internet in the country and it's even
got a nickname the gig and the city
built it itself Comcast and AT&T didn't
like that and they sued four times but
Chattanooga won here's what happened
next an independent study published by
the University of Tennessee found the
network could be directly tied to the
creation of between twenty eight hundred
and fifty two hundred new jobs it also
said the economic benefits for the city
have been roughly 1 billion dollars over
the course of the last five years but
Chattanooga success posts a great
challenge to the telecom industry which
has lobbied states across the country to
ban or limit similar experiments many
states about 20 as a matter of fact have
passed laws that make this very
difficult they basically they have
succumbed to telecommunication industry
lobbying and passed laws that give
Internet service providers the first
right of refusal
so that municipalities aren't even
allowed by law to try to create these
community broadband networks because of
lobbyists there's a Tennessee law that
makes it illegal for Chattanooga's
network to expand out into surrounding
areas and they're forbidden from
offering internet to customers at rates
that are less than the actual cost of
providing the service if we turn
accessing the technology itself into the
market that's a whole nother market we
have to go through in order just to be
viable and like I said if you're not on
certain platforms you don't exist online
so it literally gives those providers
the power to tax folks out of existence
hey guys thanks so much for watching
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and what I want to know is if any of you
or people you know have trouble getting
online tell us your stories in the
comments below and don't forget to come
back next Sunday when we have another
great video